chapter two is called the African
background of new world religions and
you know so get this term diaspora up
there what is what is that that's a term
that's not only important for this
chapter but also for some other chapters
you familiar with that term diaspora
yeah it comes from Greek comes from the
word actually the scatter Spedding
diaspora means a scatter all over the
place okay you get it remember the
parable of the sower in the Gospels you
know guy went out to sow its field and
then when you read at your life boy this
guy doesn't know farming at all because
he threw the seed all over the place and
some of it went on the road you like
sports wrong with him some of it went on
the rocky part again who throws seed
like that was his dias bearing he's
throwing it all over the place a
diaspora is when people wind up going
all over the place people who were
originally in one place who originally
have a kind of unity of culture and a
continuity with that land are sent
everywhere now how did that happen with
the Africans in the New World yeah okay
exactly a slavery was a pretty much
universal practice in any society that
developed beyond a certain level from
from antiquity on but it takes on a
different configurations depending on
culture yeah the new world slavery was
was very much used as a economic
institution the way it wasn't in other
places as well but it became tied in
with notions of race in ways that it
hadn't been before and where did most of
the slaves for the new world come from
Africa but we're in Africa all over the
place yeah
yeah very good I mean some from the
Portuguese would take them from you know
what's nowadays ain't go love but for
the most part they're coming from
countries like you know now modern-day
Nigeria Baneen Liberia right Liberia has
gone to buy freed slaves this entire
western coastline why because it's close
it was closer to the New World Brazil
was a very important place actually for
that if you look at the distance between
Zille and West Africa it's not very far
at all comparatively speaking so this is
what we call involuntary migration
involuntary immigration yeah he goes on
and talks about this he says it in there
there were different ways in which is
played out and we're interested in the
religious aspects right right now so in
South America and the West Indies or
when you do that thang Caribbean I love
that smell sight anybody know to be a
spice that works better what happened
there well there is there a more
continuity of practice of culture and
why well because slaves outnumbered the
people who are bringing them over vastly
and so they couldn't break it up you
know Haiti is a great example haiti was
also you know Hades one one side of the
island dominican republic's I'm domain
is the other side and there it was
primarily slaves that were brought in
and there weren't that many people
controlling especially your kids
europeans tend to die pretty quickly you
know in the Caribbean
in South America so there wasn't the
same sort of corrosive dissolving
influence that happen in North America
there is less continuity in part because
the slaves are being brought into not
just you know places but cultures that
already were deserting their their
influence it was a very very important
other distinction though between what
was going on in North America especially
in the British controlled areas and what
was going on in the rest of the Americas
what do you think it was what was the
other key factor that had to do with
whether you could preserve for the most
part in war or whether you and leave
behind your ancestral religion part of a
part of it is they you know they're not
paying attention to you so you get to do
what you want there was another factor
as well when they were paying attention
to you okay let's use an example from
our life that we can relate to you guys
are familiar with a double entendre
right what's a double entendre in speech
would you say one thing but you really
mean another and often tend to do this
with sexual things you know say things
that are on the surface very innocent
but can be kind of dirty because they
mean different things and if you were to
say that like in the classroom you'd be
okay because your teacher would would
not be able to punish you because you're
really you would say I only met this I'm
only talking about this but really
you're saying something way over here
right now matron your email with your
religion how might you do something like
that with religion if
wanted to continue to practice your
religion what you're used to what you
what you believe in what gives meaning
to your life especially without a year
in a really crappy existence enslaved
people telling you what to do in a place
that smells funny everything tastes
different you have no idea what's going
on as far as like you know long-term
prospects how many disguise you in
religion yeah well to completely the
South America and West Indies a lot
Africans try to adopt a lot of the
Catholic view so you trade their former
God of gods as Catholic scenes exactly
within Protestant Christianity pretend
we're going to see why we look at some
of these other chapters there is this
notion that Catholicism and Eastern
Orthodoxy they were even sometimes going
after the Anglicans on this because the
anglican czar still pretty pretty
liturgical was way too you know into
saints and rituals and things like that
and we're not going to do that we want
just the the word or you know whatever
rituals we've we've designed it seems
important it was much more difficult for
for African slaves to preserve any sort
of religious identity under those sorts
of things because there's nothing
there's no anchor points that they could
attach things too whereas if you're in a
Catholic country and the Roman Catholics
already have all these statues to Saints
why not if you want to keep on
worshiping the gods or in this case the
risotto ah who you you think are
important to you why not call them
saints why not assimilate them and so
what goes on is a process of we call
hybridization or synchronization he says
I should use the word synchronization
that's being a little bit fast Didius in
a certain sense
this is what brings about what we call
these African Diaspora religions and
we'll talk about some of the exact
shapes that these take on but what would
some of these be food yeah I think a
nation in friendship out with you like
yeah yeah you know who don't actually
not only gloves together Roman Catholic
you know call to the saint but also some
French Creek Freemasonry as well we
really become who you nor else right
because there's emigration from Haiti
after the Haitian Revolution very
important event to not only New Orleans
but to Louisiana in general and then he
also talks about this as it spreads out
for losing its integrity as a sort of
systemic religion and generating into a
bunch of folkways a bunch of practices
sometimes this is also called root work
and this is the woman that probably more
Americans are familiar with because it's
bad cos had a presence here in the
United States for a longer time a bit
more important on the world scene would
be what are often called the you know
the if a or Aruba based religions which
do you remember those being yeah yeah
literally the way the saints right this
is a way for and that would be Cuba and
some of the other neighboring here is
this would be a way for Yoruba to ride
slaves and the rube are one of the
largest peoples in West Africa on the
most influential one so a lot of slaves
are taken from you ruble and this is a
way for them to continue to practice
their religion under hundred different
aspects there are other other ones as
well condone life in brazil also to vent
in venezuela to a certain extent some
theory is also sort of recent years it's
been a lot of interaction between
Venezuela and Cuba chango in the
Caribbean Trinidad and Grenada and
though there are some other religions as
well that are that you know a bit
smaller and don't play much of a role in
the American scene unless you get into
very very small ethnic communities like
a community or bhayo but they're all
basically doing the same thing they're
all taking a religious matrix which is
there and their views and putting them
together it's not really right to say
that there is blinding them because that
makes it sound like you know it's being
watered down practitioners of if they
remove our religions see what they're
doing as just as legitimate as what's
going on still in Nigeria today with the
traditional European religion as a
matter of fact if any indigenous
religion has a claim to being called the
world religion it would be would be this
when i teach world religions that's i
teach it as a world religion because
it's spread out across multiple
continents like hinduism or buddhism or
Judaism
so if we want to understand what's going
on in these religions what we would want
to do then is go back and look at the
stock from which they came yeah I think
the best way to do this in terms of your
Ruby religion is to look at their their
notions of spiritual beings and then to
talk a bit about divination excellent
okay so we don't have that much time so
I'm going to go through this rather
quickly at the top of the hierarchy we
have this High God over literally the
owner of heaven or in his heaven so
Oliver is the owner of heaven yeah he's
the beginning of everything he creates
the other ones who who do things risa
yeah the ERISA or a reshef any I'm you
know which pronunciation you're using
but those are sort of like you can call
them demigods or you know secondary
spirits or something like that older one
is the High God but he doesn't really
have any worship as such and people
praying to him given prayers he's
actually a model for your Ruben man but
her father would to give without
expecting anything else in the church
because you know his the universe well
he leaves the day to day and even the
big things to the Ariza one of these is
actually I called his his son that would
be one of the first three sets of the
form duration Allah or I'll also come o
batala and in South Korea and there's a
whole bunch of these and they vary in
power
very and what they do I've got a you
know handout that I'm working on for you
and I've also got a I learned section so
I'm not going to talk about the
specifics I'll just bring up a few of
them that are particularly important
shondo is is originally a chieftain who
eventually becomes one of these these
guys and shondo is associated with
thunder and strategy and male fertility
he's sort of about divine Punisher if
you're doing bad things sopo no it was
originally a god of smallpox and and
smallpox that seems to be an issue he
became associated with inoculations in
general he's understood as always being
like one step ahead of science so guess
which disease he's particularly
associated with today in Africa exactly
HIV and AIDS when new diseases arise
that come under the aspect of soup ona
arisia and Allah is you know the one who
actually creates the dry lay on that
human beings live on his route as the
embodiment of logic and reason it just
keeps going on and on from from there
and these are the beings that's going to
be worshipped pray to engage through
ritual there are priesthoods for for all
of these gods some of them are more
important some of them are less
important but they're all understood as
basically being under the hug I and as
doing his or his work they're all sort
of Deputies and then we got other
spiritual beings that play a role one
very important set with the the
ancestors but some of the ancestors
actually you don't become a recent like
Shonda does right the ancestors would be
your dead relatives going back
generations in traditional African
religions the dead at least if they were
good at least if people like them so you
know if not they made me go off to some
bad
are understood as being closer to the
gods now they're giving sort of time
that's outside of outside of the time
that we're used to the the you know Elin
tempest as Eliana's calling it and they
can be used they can be relied on as
intercessors with things that are more
powerful so you want to actually retain
connection with your ancestors because
they care about you and they care about
what happens to you and you would want
to you know keep on engaging in a
continuous relationship with them and
there's you know discussions about what
sort of rights are involved in
traditional Yoruba religion the
ancestors are actually personified by
people who wear these put some pictures
and I learned for you these garments
from from top to bottom who are masked
and who are there to sort of stand in
for them the other thing that I want to
hit on that's particularly important is
you know what this term means divination
you get that term divine end right so
you guess it's gonna something to do
with God of the gods what is divination
yeah no it's not that although that's a
decent guess that would be digitization
yeah like being possessed by by the way
possession happens within these things
by to the Eyrie saw pouring in boonton
by the lowa it's not exactly that
although that's getting closer to it if
somebody was in fact possessed by one of
the gods why would that be important we
see these movies we think about
possession people doing crazy stuff but
that's yeah these are good guys so yeah
you could have a relationship with them
that's sort of face-to-face why you want
to be connected with the gods worship is
sort of I give you why am i doing I want
something in the turn right what we want
from the divine quite often yeah it's
again you won't touch with other like
kind of try to find your purpose and
very good way to get information
information again about how to restore
that which is been disrupted or how to
fix what's going along how to how to
unbreak was broken how to progress
further and in in the infant religions
one of the reasons why they're called
the affair religions is there are these
priests babalawo who are priests of
ouran Milla one of the manor recess and
they use you generally not spawn nuts or
cowrie shells in this this sort of
device to cast lots and then they
consult the text but your book doesn't
tell you my name but it's very important
cog 002 infant the 02 fo is a set of
oral stories that have been passed down
they're actually quite long and they'll
cast lotsa will say oK you've got this
problem you know I cast the Lots now
that refers to
12 4 of these design and 4402 info i'll
tell you the story and then you and I
sit here and try to figure out how that
applies to your life and your situation
that's what the bottle lot of ducks and
you know these are these are very
interesting stories and you can often
find something that's connected with it
it's very similar in many respects to
penny very familiar with the echame in
Chinese in a traditional driven with the
divination casting the euro stoxx this
is understood as a way to get
information from the divine and now what
would you want information about you
know where rate where you left your car
keys probably not although they'll be
helpful where you left your iPhone you
lose your iPhone you don't know that the
app where's my iphone what else would
you want information like the afterlife
and what happens yeah yeah but
especially about this life well how
should I live what kind of person am I
each person is understood as being under
the realm of one of these Ariza so if
you are associated with chango it'd be
good for you to know that so you don't
screw up your life by trying to live
like somebody who's actually suited to
another thing that's where we will end
today